hello
my name is gopal ashok i'm the product
manager for cloud memory store
today we're going to talk about
optimally
deploying an application cache with
memory store
so let's begin so there are a few
areas that i want to cover today um so
i'll start off with talking a little bit
about
why it is important to have an in memory
store uh
in your application architecture and
what benefits it provides
from there we'll talk a little bit about
redis and why redis is one of the most
popular in memory stores today
and from there uh we will dive into
memory store
um start with the overview of the
product what are some of the key
features and capabilities that we
provide
but more importantly the key thing that
i would like you to take away from this
presentation
is what are some of the best practices
that you should be using
when you are deploying memory store for
your application use cases
so i think we all know in stores are a
critical part of modern application
architecture
but let's take a close look at why that
is the case
without storing data and or storing and
processing data in memory
it is impossible to get the speed that
is required by applications today
and we all know that the speed of the
applications and the response time of
the application
essentially determines user retention
which essentially means it translates to
how well your business will do
so having an in-memory store that can
deliver the the speed that is required
by modern applications
is super critical the other aspect of it
is that
speed also in a way or lack of speed and
also in a way translates availability
if the website is super slow that
essentially means the website is
unavailable
so again an memory store allows you not
only just to have
the speed that is needed by the
application but it's also a critical
component to deliver on the availability
that is required
by the application the other key aspect
where in memory store comes into play
along with speed and availability is
cost so there are a lot of use cases
where
you can benefit from having an in-memory
store in front of your
database or a back-end store for example
that allow you to reduce the cost
or the total cost and when it comes to
data access
so by creating a lot more data from the
memory store you can actually
provision or downsize or right-size your
back-and-forth provisioning which can
help you
manage the overall cost for the
data access so as you can see in-memory
store
is a super critical component which
allows you to
enable your application to scale and
provide the speed
and the responsiveness that the
application needs it allows you to have
better availability
but and also helps you manage the cost
so if you take an example which is a
very common example
of user sessions or using or a session
store
typically what happens in these
scenarios is that you start off with
using a backend database as your session
store
and for example if let's say your
application
is a ticketing application and
if you're using a backend store for
backend database as your session store
it'll scale well for a certain amount of
time
but once your application takes off and
you get thousands or
hundreds of thousands of concurrent
connections you will notice that your
backend store or backend database for
example postgres is not actually going
to scale
and this is where having an in memory
store in the architecture really really
helps so you can store your sessions in
the in memory store
and basically because the processing
time and the processing is done in
memory and the processing happens within
milliseconds
your overall latency for the application
can come down from hundreds of
milliseconds in the 90th percentile to
maybe
tens of milliseconds for the 90th
percentile so having an in memory store
for your
or for scaling your application
architectures is super super important
today
so let's take a look at what are some of
the you know popular
choices when it comes to memory store i
think when you look at
usage it is there's no argument that
redis is the most popular store today
you can argue most applications
regardless of industry or vertical
use or can benefit from redis and the
popularity is reflected in in db engines
which is a popular website for rating
databases and also in this stack
overflow survey where
users developers and admin devops
folks rated redis as the most loved
database so it's super clear that redis
is a very very popular database
or in memory store and that that that is
used across applications today
why spread is so popular redis is an
extremely fast in memory store that
provides sub-millisecond processing but
more importantly it provides rich data
structures that allow
application developers to do computation
fast computations of applications logic
on the server side
on top of that redis also provides
capabilities like pub sub and streaming
which allows it
allows you know developers to build um
queueing applications streaming
application
and that too at a very high scale apart
from that redis also provides a high
availability and
scaling features that allows predators
to be used across a wide variety of use
cases
at varying scale so all together
redis has become the number one choice
for
in in memory stores for building modern
application architecture
so if you're migrating to gcp or
building new applications on gcp
cloud memory store provides you a fully
managed
redis and memcached service uh on gcp so
if you are either migrating your
application from on-prem
or if you are migrating an application
from a different cloud
or if you are managing your own redis on
gce
you now have a fully managed redis and
memcached service that you can
that you can use um to deploy your retis
and
memcached instances i think the key
thing
about having a memory store as a fully
managed service
is that it takes away the burden of
managing
the caching infrastructure so let's take
a look at some of the key features and
capabilities of memory store
at the highest level as i mentioned
memory store provides a fully managed
redis and memcached service
the service is built on open source
redis and memcached
which means you can easily lift and
shift your applications with
very minimum effort the other thing that
we enable
is that maintaining a caching
infrastructure is not
easy especially when you have to
maintain a highly available caching
infrastructure
so if you were to do it yourself then
you'll have to maintain a proxy layer
you have to manage all the vms you have
to make sure that you patch the vms etc
and with memory store we take care of
all that for you with our own health
checks
automatic fade over monitoring etc and
on top of that you get the google create
security
where we ensure that the infrastructure
is deployed in a very secure environment
where we use private ips and you have
restricted access to specific networks
etc
so overall with memory store you get a
fully managed service
that is highly available and also highly
secure
and with that you don't really have to
spend time managing your redis and
memcached infrastructure you can just
focus on building your applications
so let's take a closer look at some of
the capabilities that we provide
for memory surface so memory surface
comes in two flavors
a basic tier and a standard tier the
basic tier is a standalone instance of
radius the standard tier is
a highly available instance of redis
with a primary and a replica
uh we support up to 300 gigabytes in
data set size but the key thing that i
want
i want you to note here is that the both
the tiers are essentially single primary
so that means we don't support scale out
architecture yet
so the qps that memory source supports
is limited to what a single primary can
support
so when you architect your application
that is something that you should keep
in mind and i'll talk more about that in
the best practices section
apart from that we provide a backup so
if you're using
memory store as a critical or primary
store
um you can take backups of your data so
in case of catastrophic failure you can
restore
from the backup and we support multiple
versions including redis version
5.0 we've also been working on some new
features
over the over the last few months um so
we have
shipped a redis version 5.0 but one of
the other key features that we have
shipped is
support for shared vpc so if you're
deploying uh
applications and service projects and
you want to deploy memory store using a
shared vpc network you can do that today
so before this feature um was enabled
you were not able to deploy
memory sources in service projects you
had to deploy it in the host project
but now you will be able to do that one
thing to note here is that this feature
today is only available as part of
g cloud we are working on the ui but if
you look into the documentation
you will see the steps that you'll have
to go through to enable shared vpc
for memory store and lastly we also
enable support for vpc service controls
so if you're using vpc service controls
memory store works very seamlessly with
it
we're also excited to announce that we
have
we are providing support for memcache d
as part of memory store
so what we have heard from customers is
that there are a lot of memcached
deployments out there for legacy
applications and even for some new
applications customers would like to use
my cachet
and with the support from memcached
today now you have a fully
managed memcached instance that is
available
with memory store the memcache instance
is
a scale out architecture so we support
up to 20 nodes you can scale from 1 to
20 nodes and you
can have individual shots up to 256 gigs
with 32 vcpus so we provide a lot of
flexibility in terms of shaping your
cluster
for the different types of application
workloads that you may have
for memcached um one of the other key
things that we provide as part of the
service is the discovery endpoint
which allows you to basically discover
all the nodes in the cluster from an
application perspective
so that way when you're scaling your
clusters in and out you
always on you always know what your
topology looks like
and you don't have to basically change
your app configurations
uh when you just scale your clusters up
and down so that's a very convenient
service that allows you to minimize the
amount of work that you
need to do whenever you do scaling of
a memcached cluster so we are super
excited about
you know enabling memcached for you we
are currently in beta
and we will be doing ga pretty soon
okay so we touched upon a few things we
touched upon why caching is important we
touched upon
um some of the um benefits of using
redis and we talked about
memory store but the key thing that i
want to talk about for the remaining
time that we have in this presentation
is about the use cases and patterns
and based on that what is the best
practices that you should follow
when you are deploying memory store so
let's take a look at the use cases and
patterns
so the way we look at use cases
is when it comes to red especially
redis supports a wide variety of use
cases
so from a simple web content cache or a
database cache
to you know distributed log
recommendation engines
threat detection fraud detection whatnot
so there are a wide variety of use cases
that redis is used for
but the key thing to understand is that
each of these use cases
maps to four different what i call
caching patterns
and the caching patterns essentially
determines
the behavior that is expected from that
caching
layer for that particular use case so we
see four different use
of caching patterns ephemeral cache the
capacity cache
the transient store and the primary
store and for
and i'll talk more about the
characteristics of these patterns in the
next slide
but along with the patterns there is
also the workload pattern which
essentially determines the scale in
terms of data set size
and the qps the read write ratio for the
application when it comes to
accessing the cache and also the uh the
payload size
so the combination of the workload
patterns along with the caching patterns
determines
what type of deployment you should be
doing for your particular use case
so let's take a look at the different
caching patterns and what that really
means
so ephemeral cache you can think of it
as a very simple cache if the cache goes
away
you can rehydrate the cache from a
backend store there is no
real impact to the application except
for maybe a slow performance small
performance degradation that is
not significant from an application
perspective
and for these kind of use cases it may
be enough to just deploy
you know memcache or the basic tier of
redis which is actually very very cheap
but when it comes to the transient store
use case it becomes a little bit more
interesting
so you have a use case like session
store where you have
you want to store the keys for a certain
amount of time
but you want the key keys to be
available for that period of time
because if you lose the key then the
user experience suffers
again it is not catastrophic but again
you don't but again the user experience
can get impacted which can also
translate
to translate to um bad customer
satisfaction and customers probably
you know leaving your service so you
want to make sure that when you have
use cases like session store your keys
are highly available
the primary store becomes an even more
interesting use case where
it is a primary store that is backing
your for example your front-end
um website and that data doesn't exist
anywhere else the data is typically
processed by offline processing during
the day
and it is you know ingested into a redis
instance and that essentially acts as
the primary store for
the applications using it so it's super
important for that layer to be highly
available
and for that particular use case it is
also important to ensure that
the instance is very highly available
but you also want to ensure that the
data is backed up
uh in case there is a counter-strike
failure so that you can recover
um using the backup um when the failure
happens
and lastly capacity cache is interesting
from the perspective of how customers
deploy the cache so one of the key
things that
capacity cache is used for is to
basically front a database
and to ensure that the back-end store is
not impacted as much so what that means
is that when you deploy your capacity
cache
you want to split your key space across
a large number of nodes
and so that even if one or two node
fails the
the impact on the back end um so
back end database is constrained and you
don't really
get into the thundering hub problem so
this is where the memcache deployment
can help because now you can spread your
data across
a large number of nodes and minimize the
blast radius
if a node goes down so these are some of
the four different
caching patterns that we see so what i
want to talk about now
is if your application use case
fits into one of these caching patterns
what are some of the best practices that
you should be following to ensure that
you're running the memory store instance
optimally
for your application workload so
the first thing that i would like you to
do is to understand
and follow the memory management best
practices for redis
one of the things that redis is
notorious for is for memory management
but as a managed service we do a lot of
things behind the scenes to ensure that
we take care of some of the
inefficiencies in terms of memory
management
that happens in redis for you but having
said that
it is super important for you to follow
the best practices
and and especially follow you know
monitoring the right metrics to ensure
that
your instance is running optimally
so let's look take a look at some of the
metrics that you should be monitoring
so we have there are four key metrics
and from our perspective that you should
be monitoring if you are using memory so
when it comes to memory usage the first
one is a system memory usage ratio
the system memory usage ratio basically
tells you
how much system memory is getting used
in your instance
so system memory also includes memory
that is consumed by memory fragmentation
so if your instance or your workload is
causing a lot
of memory fragmentation then the system
memory usage ratio will tell you
whether the fragmentation is higher or
not so
you absolutely should monitor system
memory usage ratio and ideally set a
threshold of about 80
so that you can start making right
sizing your instances
uh once that threshold is hit the other
one is memory usage ratio that basically
tells you
whether your deployed uh instance
is basically being used optimally from a
data usage perspective
the next one is also very interesting
and something that we introduced
recently
which is the time and system memory
overload so what happens behind the
scenes is that
we have put a cap in terms of system
memory beyond which we start blocking
rights
so when we do that the whole idea is
that we
ensure that there is enough system
memory available and the system will not
go into an unstable state or
crash but the experience that you will
get when you hit that limit
is essentially out of memory errors on
your applications when you try to do
rights
so one of the things that you want to
monitor is that is your instance getting
into that condition
um or not right it could be that there
are some
peak workloads where you briefly get
into that condition but then
the steady state is actually you know
okay
but it's something to keep monitoring
which will allow you to
determine whether you need to go right
size your instance or not
and lastly evictions is an interesting
good thing to monitor to ensure that if
you have
you know eviction policies set where you
expect the keys to be evicted you want
to monitor that
you know either the ttl is set or the
keys are getting evicted so that the
memory is managed optimally
so we highly recommend that if you're
using memory store
you always monitor these metrics and set
thresholds or rather alerts that
can proactively tell you whether your
instance is
getting into a bad state or not so
once you've done the memory usage uh
best practices and the monitoring around
that
the next thing you want to do is based
on the signals that you get
you want to be able to right size your
instance so like i mentioned earlier
the system memory usage ratio is a very
good indicator of how well
your system or instance is performing in
terms of memory consumption
so if you go beyond 80 what you would
want to do
is you want to bright size your instance
by lowering the max memory
um flag which we have provided as a
gcloud option
which will allow you to give more
overhead for the for the instance
this is super important especially when
you are doing things like backup or you
are scaling the instance
often because when you do a backup or
when you scale the instance we do kick
off
an rdb process which essentially
is a child process that we spin up
that can consume you know even double
the memory that you're using depending
on the right rate on your
on your uh instance so especially if
your
instance is a right heavy instance we
highly recommend that you provide
higher more overhead by lowering max
memory
to ensure that operations like backup
and scaling
can happen successfully
so that's about right sizing uh the
instance so
just to recap monitor your memory
management best practices
and right size based on the thresholds
that you see for system memory usage
ratio
or the metric around
time and out of memory condition
and finally i just wanted to touch upon
some general best practices that you
should be following
especially for the primary story use
case so one of the things that i
mentioned earlier is that
the memory store in instances today both
basic and sanitary instances are
single primary meaning
all your application queries are going
against a single
uh primary so what that means is that
you want to be able to run your
benchmark for your application and
understand whether
the um the qps especially the qps is
hitting the limits
um the other thing i would say is that
if you have a write
intensive workload uh meaning if it is
you know 80 20 reads versus 50 50 you
know
read write you really want to monitor
your memory usage
like um and follow the best practices
that i mentioned in the previous slide
it is super critical you do that so that
you can keep your instance right size
and not only that you can also determine
whether you're hitting the limits of the
memory for instance
one of the ways you can hit the limits
of the memory for instance and determine
whether you're
hitting the limits of the memories for
instance is by monitoring the
replication lab
so if there's a lot of rights and if
replication is not keeping up
then what can potentially happen is that
you're giving failover you can lose some
keys that has not been replicated
um and you can basically
run into scenarios where there's a lot
of key space loss if the replication lag
is too much so you basically want to
monitor
and lastly if you're using it as a
primary store you absolutely should take
a backup of your instance
althea published a paper um on how to
schedule
backups using cloud scheduler so that is
um that is published in our solution
website
and we have also published a solution
paper around
best practices around performance from
memory store redis
in general so i'd highly recommend if
you're using memory search today or
thinking about using memory store
that you follow the best practices
around memory management
and you follow you monitor the metrics
that is recommended
and also learn how to take actions
depending on what the metrics are
telling you
so by doing that we are essentially
being proactive
about ensuring that the memory store
instance run in a stable state
and it also more importantly allows you
to determine
whether the memory store uh instance
is actually a suitable for your
workloads
in some cases if you find the memory
store instances are not
able to keep up then you will have to
shard your memory store
or application workload across multiple
memory store instances
using client-side shopping so that
hopefully gives you a general
understanding of what are some of the
best practices that you should be
following when using memory store
and i hope that you find it useful and
and
it is something that you can put into
practice immediately
so with that i just want to touch upon
uh
some useful links that will help you
um understand a lot more about what i've
just
talked about here so if you there's a
memory management
best practices documentation uh that we
have published
we have published the performance during
best practices and we also have
published a solution paper
on how to schedule backups
using cloud scheduler um all this
together hopefully it will give you
a great start in terms of running your
memory store instance optimally
thank you very much
you